as with all these things I saw a video
on YouTube of something similar and
decided I'd like to do it myself just
for if I could do it I'm Alex I'm a PhD
student in computer science here at
Nottingham and we're looking at my
musical floppy drives about 18 months
ago I came across a video on youtube or
something similar some guy had taken a
load of hobby drives and made them play
music and I thought I could do that
in each of the poppy drives there's
stepper motor which drives the
read/write heads up and down so in the
three and half inch floppy drives these
ones the stepper motors these round
things here and that rotates and it
moves the read/write head in and out
[Music]
each of these stepper motors the small
ones here and on the five mcourser
drivers well there we go it's a very big
motor the disc for the three-and-a-half
inch floppy discs is divided into 80
tracts radially from the centre and on
the fiber core so it's disc originally
that I think they had 40 tracks
there are high-density ones that can
have 80 tracks so the fact this drive
has got a switch on the front so you can
switch between 40 tracks or 80 tracks
the read/write head can move up one step
at a time up to 80 steps what we're
doing is pulsing the motor you pulse it
at the rate of a note you want to play
so every musical note has a certain
frequency
so you just pulse the motor at that
when you had a poppy disc in your
computer you'd hear it making noises you
get similar effect with inkjet printers
as they go up and down in this case
we're explicitly controlling the speed
at which it's running so normal it
doesn't matter as long as it does the
right amount of steps and it does it
everything in the right order in this
case we want it to go exactly at the
right frequency so it makes exactly the
right note on an IDE hard drive like
this it looks fairly similar to a floppy
drive connector there's a few more pins
I guess but on this the controller is on
the hard disk itself so it's somewhere
on one of these chips now what that
means is when this is plugged into a
motherboard the motherboard just says
read me this bit of data from from this
position and the hard drive will know
how to do that it goes off and spins the
right place and send you the data back
on a floppy drive like this the
controller is on the motherboard so
there's nothing very clever on the
floppy drive and what that means is it's
a lot easier for us to tell the floppy
drive what to do in terms of making the
motor move directly on each of these
floppy drives you will see there are two
connectors going in there's the power
connector which is this these ones so
that's just a power the drive the other
cable you'll see is a ribbon connector
the cables coming out of these ribbon
cables see there's two blacks agreeing
in the blue the blacks are just ground
the green in the blue one is step one is
direction okay so if the direction pin
is held low it will move in one
direction and when it's held high so
probably at five volts it will move
another direction and the step pin
whenever you pulse that it will move one
step in the direction of the direction
pin all these cables they plug into this
Arduino here nerd we know is it's almost
like a small computer on the board it's
not quite that but it's a small
programmable board it's got all sorts of
input and output pins a lot of hobbyists
use it in little projects to make robots
work or there's a whole community of
people out there that use Arduino to do
things the Arduino has got a little
program running on it which is talked to
by another program on the computer down
on this USB cable so on my computer it's
a Java program and that sends messages
down the USB to the Arduino it sends one
message per Drive and it tells it when
to start a drive going and what
frequency to make it run and when to
stop it there'll be thousands of
messages being sent down the USB cable
per second each of the Poppy drives the
read/write head can only be in one of
eight of places okay and the Java
programs let me know that so it doesn't
know when to flip the direction to pin
what the Arduino does that keeps track
of the position of the drive so you just
tell it to make this drive run at this
frequency and the Arduino will know
exactly which position each Drive head's
in and know where to reverse it if you
didn't do that it would get to the end
and it would just go you know it would
just sort of jam up against the end I
guess the Arduino has it's kind of
abstracted away the complexity of the
floppy drive so the program on computers
need to know about the floppy drives it
just says playlist note for this long
the software itself reads MIDI files
it's literally just a sequence of notes
and amid you can have lots of different
channels each separate channel can have
a separate instrument so you know track
0 could be the piano track 1 could be a
trumpet something like that
unfortunately with the floppy drives
they all sound the same and we can't
really do anything about
in a MIDI file you can control the
volume of each note as well whereas
again the floppy drives you can't really
do that they play at one volume I didn't
write this code the guy who uploaded the
original video I saw had a bonus encode
both the Arduino and unter on the
computer in Java so I've edited bits of
it rather than having to edit the MIDI
files I can just drag some sliders
around this is the program here so I can
load flight the bumblebee this is a bit
I added one of the drives is
particularly loud well this allows us to
do is to change Drive - to play channel
once everyone's - now I think flight of
the bumblebee uses channel 1 & 2
predominantly so I'll just swap these
around a bit
okay and also what we've got here we've
got two sliders this one lets us
transpose the notes so that means to put
them up or down in pitch if you like I
can fiddle with it while it's playing
and you'll be able to hear it I put the
slider down to the bottom so it's
playing five Oscars lower than it should
be so the first thing notice is the
drives are moving very slightly and
making a very very nice noise so the
drives aren't very good at playing low
notes we found that out I guess so I can
put it back up a few octaves the drive
stopped moving faster
if I put it up even further
I think it's the point we start to break
the stepper motors you know I think I've
done something horrible so I know it's
finished right okay so yeah sometimes it
does that White House called the power
out okay
hopefully that'll reset itself now there
certainly are some limitations the
original program would only play a
certain subset of notes by decided why
not put them all in I think we just God
why why not now
[Music]
well it's supposed to have stopped but
so it's gotten lost somewhere no well we
go fix